bonjour je suis génial je suis l'un des
associés de ré une munition réunion
édition est une société d'édition et une
régie publicitaire ou commercialisons à
la réunion plusieurs journaux magazines
et supports publicitaires le chr journal
qui est le journal professionnel des
cafetiers hôteliers restaurateurs presse
et communication qui est le magazine de
la presse les médias et de la
communication à la réunion pis pocket
qui est un magazine culturel nous sommes
également propriétaire du réseau flash
cards qui est un réseau de cartes
postales publicitaires nous sommes
également régie publicitaire de support
l'eco austral le magazine économique de
jeu sur un dia est géré affichage qui
est un réseau d'affichage urbain
aujourd'hui réunion édition se compose
de deux associés donc emmanuel robert et
moi même de commerciaux un graphiste
pour toute la partie
maquettes et montage
également de rédacteur en chef pour le
chr journal est pressé communication et
nous avons également un service de
livraison pour assurer justement le
réassort des campagnes flash cards et la
livraison des pickpockets au lieu de
distribution
réunion éditions cherche aujourd'hui un
livreur qui fasse le réassort des
campagnes flash cards sur toute l'île et
qui livrent également le magazine pif
pocatière l'ensemble de ces points de
distribution on recherche quelqu'un qui
sache s'intégrer à une équipe puisque
cette personne devra travailler en
relation avec la direction commerciale
de réunions édition ce livreur devra
bien entendu disposer du permis de
conduire c'est un poste à mi temps que
l'on propose il nous faut quelqu'un de
rigoureux quelqu'un qui sache travailler
en autonomie quelqu'un qui connaisse
bien la géographie de l'île puisque il
va falloir aller un petit peu partout
sur les 270 points de distribution du
réseau il faut également bien sûr
quelqu'un qui soit dynamique de souriant
sera le représentant direct de la marque
flash cards auprès des patrons
d'établissements dans lesquelles se
trouvent les panneaux flash cards si ce
poste vous intéresse c'est que vous
voulez intégrer une équipe jeune et
dynamique n'hésitez pas à nous contacter
à bientôt